Trump is capitalizing on this and he's
calling for other candidates to drop out
every dollar spent attacking me by
Republicans is a dollar given straight
to the Biden campaign if he makes it I
don't know if he's going to make it
every dollar spent attacking me is a
dollar given to Biden and he says he
says the other candidates they need to
drop out of this race I see why Trump
would say that especially now while he's
flying high in the polls but the
political reality is there is no reason
for DeSantis to drop out of this race
DeSantis has already killed himself
killed any shots that he's got being
appointed in a trump Administration
hence same thing what what else is Pence
going to do he has no reason to get out
of the race Christy he's got no reason
to get out of the race he's come out
against Trump too what's his political
future nothing so he's going to stay in
the race same with Vivek vague came out
of nowhere and he has proved himself to
be an extremely compelling political
Talent